[Music]
is it easy for you to keep your burn
rate down because like uh i i was
telling sam this i spend like i don't
know 25 000 a month now just like
and i'm not i don't even feel like i'm
dude i think sean you might spend i
think you might spend more than that now
if i bet you add it up because i know
how you spend i bet you it's more than
25. it might be it might be a little
more uh but it's not more than 30 i
would say i don't think it's more than
30. so i but like it's yeah i got two
little kids but i got two little kids
but they're like babies like like you
know like
they don't they don't eat food you know
so so you know there's diapers sure but
like it's not them it's meat
so
you said it's a steep burn rate or it's
a
good burn rate i would take it i'll
trade with you okay gotcha so when you
say you don't spend much what do you say
is your monthly burner because i think
for most people listening right they
like most people don't talk about how
much they make or how much they spend
all right how much you make sometimes
that's sensitive how much you spend
how much
well but but neil you actually wrote
this in a blog post you said uh you said
i spend this is i don't know if you're i
actually i have no idea if you're single
or if you have a family and you can
avoid that
right now but you used to say in your
blog post that you go 15 000 a month is
all i need i'm happy that was like 10
years ago i think but
that's but you used to say 15 000.
single and no kids is easy right now if
i had a guess on my burn rate 120 to 180
a month what that's insane so what is
how does that break down so what what's
the like what's the bulk of it whether
so house probably is the biggest one
no i have no mortgage okay so you're
spending 120 180 k without spending
anything on your home
uh property tax property tax
uh for both my homes and hoa dues is
probably close to 200 a year
okay great
so
[Music]
we've got 12 000 of the way there where
all right yeah
yeah
so there's
okay life insurance is 25 grand a month
what
my whole life policy yeah that's 25 to
300 a year
uh no no wait wait what what the hell is
a 25 000 a month life insurance policy
what can you explain that this is just a
benefit like if i die my wife and kids
get money
like a life insurance policy
yeah well i get that but is that normal
i've never heard uh like either i'm dumb
or you're dumb who's dumb here
am i dumb because i've never heard of
anybody spending that much on their life
insurance it's like an investment
account it builds over time
so it's not like it goes away right most
life insurance policies are for
call it 10 years then you buy another
one mine just keep going and you can
borrow against it just think of it as
like a investment vehicle so that's 25 a
month okay
now i understand
staff
cleaners nannies driver we have a
full-time driver i think that ends up
being around 57 a month
um
fifty seven hundred fifty seven thousand
thousand
uh
you know
a driver uber
what why are you more affordable so
i optimize for convenience in vegas
i go through this company they charge a
hefty premium i go through this company
and i have decals on my car so if i do a
meeting in front of a casino the car can
just stay in front of the casino it
doesn't have to move if i'm going to the
airport you can straight up pull up into
the plane or whatever you want to do and
you don't have to go through terminals
or anything like that so that makes it
like so part of your strategy as i'm
picking this up is that you live the
best lifestyle you want
and it's all expensible the way you do
it
uh i don't know if it's all expensive
isn't that what you meant with the decal
like it's a company it's like marketing
it's like a like a marketing vehicle for
you
so there there's a limo company if i
have their own
windows i pay them
i can end up parking wherever i want in
theory not literally wherever i want but
in most cases i can park wherever i want
the car can just sit there and wait for
me so all right so what else anything
else do you fly private he's like i buy
a daily disneyland fast pass just in
case i decide to go that day
yeah yeah that's like you have a
convenience of time um what's been
what's been the number one uh like kind
of like where you feel like most people
don't most people think this is too
expensive and not worth it but for me i
get way more value i'll give you an
example in my life right so i i thought
i had burned right till we started
talking so this is great i'm feeling so
much better about myself but the one
thing i did was i hired a private chef
so i was like all right
that i think i i always thought that's
the lifestyle of the rich and famous and
i thought wow that's cool cause you eat
healthy and it tastes great you don't
have to fuss with time and you know
cooking and dishes and groceries and all
that stuff
and so to me it's like a no-brainer i'm
like dude anybody with any kind of money
you should be like that should be one of
the first like fancy car later
private chef now like because i'm like
to me the value the reward way outweigh
the cost i think most people don't
typically make that trade sounds like
you've experimented with many ways of
spending money
what has been a good reward for
for cost uh trade that you're like
this one is is great that most people
don't do
i i don't know i mean i'm in a bubble
because i have a lot of friends who are
like me sadly uh in which we spend a lot
we don't know what's reality i know that
sounds bad to say but it's true right uh
cook is not bad
uh housekeepers and best you don't have
to do your own dishes and stuff although
funny enough i enjoy doing that and
ironing because it's uh it's kind of
like meditative for me it's relaxing i
don't know why watching tv and ironing
um
nanny's help so you get the freedom and
you can watch your kids when you want to
but you can also do meetings and stuff
like that
um
probably the the best expense i ever
spend on is private planes
not because i like it it's uh i don't
mind playing commercial not really any
difference for me but it helps me
optimize for time so that way i can see
my kids more
i have to sometimes do a lot of meetings
for work and just going and coming back
the same day just really in and out
really quickly like sometimes i'll be
home quick enough like go from vegas to
utah for a conference speak come back
and i'll be home quick enough to pick up
my kid from school i like to meet really
well valuable that's worth money are you
saving any money then or i mean are you
just taking a fat draw from the agency
in order to
pay for this or are you able to expense
a lot of it to the agency how does that
work i don't expense any of it to my
company
i just personally paid
so you're just the agency's just that
profitable of a business it's doing that
well
or investments or savings i've done well
enough in life where i'm okay
[Music]
can we turn the ship around we need to
circle back
business term